this is a production of Cornell
University
it has been sort of a wild ride and it
does amaze me that you know just a few
years ago I was a plant pathologist and
a fungal ecologist you know but those
themes really do uh translate into my
current work which really approaches the
same Central issues of vulnerability and
and of food insecurity from different
and multiplicative ways so I'm really
happy to share those uh learnings with
you and hopefully draw uh connect my
work at Cornell with my work at gain and
show how these things really do build on
each other and how the NGO space is a
real way to build a career for us
sitting in in this in this room right
now and so on so yeah it is a pleasure
to be back here and uh and also a unique
opportunity because I defended my
dissertation in the time of zoom and so
I didn't get this chance to stand in
front of my department during those days
so uh a really great opportunity for me
in more ways than one so today uh what
I'm going to be really talking about is
how plant science and agricultural
research in general really does have the
power more broadly to shape communities
and to uplift vulnerable smallholders in
the context of food system
transformation so um I'll I'll share
some of that with you today but I do
first want to
uh make the argument that uh people are
really at the very center of food
systems and that they're an integral
part of Food Systems transformation
which is not something that's vague and
bureaucratic but something that really
has meaningful relevance for the lived
realities of people who consume the food
and produce the food and get food into
the markets so um Food Systems really do
have to work for the humans that power
them it has to work for farmers and for
their families and for the system actors
across food value chains that connect
the farm to the dinner plate and
ultimately build up meaningful
livelihoods so um and today I'm going to
approach these uh themes from a couple
of different perspectives first uh the
theoretical boring one I guess which is
sort of the definition of what is a food
system and what does it mean to
transform Food Systems and particularly
in the context of this talk what value
can be gained by applying a community
lens to the task of Food Systems
transformation and uh secondly I'll
um explore in a little more practical
detail some methods that can be deployed
for engaging communities in this process
of Food Systems transformation so it'll
hopefully come down from the theoretical
and you get to see some practical
insights and approaches and then I'll
wrap up at today's presentation by
explaining a bit about gain what we do
at the Global Alliance for improved
nutrition and how this overall context
of Food Systems transformation really
drives our work and and hopefully
enables us to do right by those uh
vulnerable consumers in the countries
where we work and I'll try to leave some
time at the end for questions and
discussion although I'm notoriously bad
at that so
um we'll see how things go so uh first
uh just to
um
ground ourselves in this idea of a food
system what does what does that even
mean what are we talking about here so
uh basically a food system encompasses
the Myriad actions and processes that
are required for the production and
consumption of food and these food
systems are contextualized within
certain environments like Villages or
states or watersheds or other units of
space but they're also contextualized
within timelines that have real
connection to human cultures and systems
like cropping calendars and and
religious holidays and these sorts of
things these are all aspects of food
systems and um you know there's this
kind of reductive but mostly useful
linearization of what a food system
means from the pre-production context of
you know making sure that there are land
rights and inputs and the seeds that are
you know that set Farmers up well to
produce the food that they need all the
way through production and processing
and Retail to that point where the food
lands in the kitchen and in the pantry
of the people who actually eat it and
that's the point when it can translate
into nutrition outcomes
um and then there's also a growing
discussion around this final stage in
that linear model of food waste and how
much we can stand to gain in improving
the functioning of Our Food Systems by
minimizing that waste and by disposing
of of unused or underused food properly
and effectively so
um that's sort of what we mean when we
think about the definition of a food
system but today what I'm going to be
talking about more specifically are are
these drivers of food systems that
determine the extent to which uh the
production and consumption of food
enabled by Food Systems is adequate to
meet nutritional needs of vulnerable
populations now Food Systems
transformation is really this process of
exacting structural change to paradigms
of food production and consumption that
make food systems more Equitable for All
actors in that food system and that make
it profitable for people who are engaged
in these food value chains so that they
can earn a dignified living from working
the land and from perpetuating hopefully
sustainable system of production and
consumption and also it transformation
is about making food systems sustainable
in light of uh unparalleled
environmental degradation and climate
change that is increasingly affecting
our the ability of Food Systems to
nourish populations especially in more
volatile food system contexts
so um
continuing on a dreary train of thought
let's just explore the argument that
right now food systems are enduring an
unprecedented crisis food systems are
broken and imperiled by compounding
stresses the covid-19 pandemic which
rocked the world and importantly Supply
chains for food
and furthermore the war in Ukraine which
has upended Supply chains and introduced
unknown uncertainty about the
availability and affordability of food
for people who need it the most and all
of that together with degrading
environments and increasingly volatile
production contexts has um meant that
value chains especially for high-value
perishable foods which happen to be
those that are the most nutritious and I
arguably the most important have been
extremely affected by by all of these
stresses and the result of this sort of
Crisis moment for Global Food Systems
has been an undoing of much of the
progress we have made to correct uh
nutrition security to Ill to eradicate
malnutrition or to address the drivers
of malnutrition so while we had reached
over the past decade a a plateau in the
extent of malnourishment and we're on
the brink of correcting that issue we've
seen as a result of covid and these you
know intersecting tragedies a Resurgence
of of malnutrition and and numerous
people falling into poverty and
nutrition insecurity to an extent that
we haven't seen in in years so food
systems are broken in a lot of ways but
that's not to say that they can't be
fixed so how do we go about fixing food
systems addressing all of these
vulnerabilities and this really is the
work of of Food Systems transformation
uh really critical to the work of
transformation is uh ameliorating Power
imbalances that systematically limit
um consumers access to nutritious foods
and and producers access to profitable
and sustainable markets for those Foods
so um the resources uh
really in food systems are are necessary
to safeguard the productive capacity of
of those value chains
um and the way that resources are
administered means a lot in terms of who
has the power to influence Food Systems
change and to what extent vulnerable
people are able to participate and
inform processes of Food Systems
transformation so what we're going to be
thinking about today
um in in the context of this talk is
that particular element of power
imbalance and how we can make small
steps toward correcting those imbalances
and giving a platform and a voice to
vulnerable communities by infusing the
process of Food Systems transformation
with Community Based and and
farmer-oriented methods that really help
ensure that the agenda for Food Systems
transformation reflects the needs of
farmers and other value chain actors
so
um thinking a bit more about
vulnerability uh what does what does
that mean and what does that look like
and what are sort of the the grounds for
for involving people
um vulnerability is really important
because it constrains the potential for
change the more vulnerable you are the
more risk-averse you are and the more
resistant to disrupting the status quo
you might be
um and it's important to note that
vulnerability is not just a measure of
income or monetary poverty but it
reflects this multi-dimensional concept
of deprivation or multi-dimensional
poverty which includes your income but
also your access to basic infrastructure
and services and importantly education
these things really make a difference
when it comes to how empowered and
emboldened Food Systems actors can be to
take part in these processes but also
very importantly
vulnerability is you know as communal
and Collective as it is deeply personal
and it's exactly this shared nature of
vulnerability at the community level
that is a foundation for Collective
action and really is the precedent for
the potential of com of community-based
approaches to
um to allow Food Systems change to be
informed by by individuals so
um you know when we think about this we
can ask ourselves a number of questions
that can help ground these challenges in
human realities when we think about how
vulnerability impacts interactions with
Food Systems we might ask ourselves is
there a good road connecting our village
to the market or will people take me
seriously even though I never went to
school you know or how can I possibly
focus on nutrition when my house keeps
flooding you know these are just a few
hypothetical examples of very real
realities and vulnerabilities that
exclude vulnerable but important system
actors from participating in the process
of Food Systems transformation
um so with this in mind I I want to move
on to sort of the main argument of of
the talk which is that Collective action
particularly at the community level can
be a catalyst for Food Systems
transformation by uh a swaging the
vulnerabilities and dispersing that risk
across populations giving giving
vulnerable people a platform and a voice
that they wouldn't ordinarily have as
individual food system actors so
um Collective action in the context of
communities basically means you know
coming together to address shared
concerns with methods that make sense in
a local context
um and by embracing Collective action as
a community it allows a Cooperative of
individually vulnerable people to exert
power through a number of functions it
diffuses risk
across a broader number of people so
that there's a comfort and security in
adopting an innovation mindset you know
people might not feel comfortable
risking their livelihood on an important
Food Systems question or important
farming decision by themselves but if
they do it as part of a collective
that's a sort of insurance
and a a mechanism of support that they
can rely on and trust it also
facilitates learning where lesson
learned from one farmer can meaningfully
connect to the experience of others and
to have entire communities and really
facilitate this atmosphere of growth and
of Cooperative action that can be very
powerful
Collective action at the community level
also reduces dependencies of vulnerable
people on institutions that may not be
set up well or functioning properly
enough to effectively address the needs
in ways that are meaningful to them and
it confers important power because there
is power in numbers and you know 40
Farmers or 400 Farmers talking about the
importance of a single issue has a lot
more importance than one farmer is
talking about the importance of that
issue so it really does confer power for
vulnerable people to shape processes of
decision making and lastly
um but not least in in the slightest is
that Collective action is a as a driver
of resilience it allows communities to
absorb shocks like droughts or or like
floods
um and and other other calamities that
may otherwise jeopardize the ability of
a community to produce and consume
sufficiently Nutri just food
so this all I argue is one route to Food
Systems transformation because through
these functions and and more
um Collective action and community-based
research
um really does promote Equitable access
to uh markets as well as you know
nutritious food and it does have the
promise of improving livelihood through
you know promoting opportunities for
income growth and dignified work
um and uh it does also through its
potential to embed Community
perspectives in the halls of power
help to influence governance at the food
system scale that is responsive to
communities needs
so
um this is all to say that
community-based research can be rather
game changing for vulnerable communities
who are effectively mobilized and I'll
illustrate this with a hypothetical
example
um you know if we look at the
relationship at the community level like
if all of these dots represent
communities
um you know there's a relationship
between the amount of supportedness a
community experiences and the amount of
vulnerability they endure and so if we
for example embed meaningful
participatory community-based research
um at a community level it has the
potential to reduce vulnerability and to
increase the support that that Community
feels and uh so this is you know a
reason why communities are very rightly
seen as focal points of Food Systems
transformation is because there's this
very real opportunity to push entire
communities toward a more resilient and
supportive way of life
um and you know this this process of
embedding community-based methods in a
in a community can support uh access to
markets and agricultural inputs and and
essential services and I'll go into some
examples uh later on in the talk but
before I do I just want to also draw
attention to a more Insidious problem
that is a Perpetual challenge even for
um even for regular practitioners of
community-based and participatory
research which is that they're both
inter and intra-specific power
imbalances that shape the way Food
Systems transformation trickles down to
the most vulnerable members of
individual communities like if we look
within a single Community toward the
actors who participate in these sorts of
research Endeavors we can see that
sometimes you know the ones who are most
involved in the research or who have the
most power to affect the trajectory of a
participatory program are those that are
the most entire to have the highest
social status perhaps meaning that the
benefits of research are less felt by
those who are experiencing the most
vulnerability in those communities so
this is another important Dimension
traditional or classical
community-based participatory research
often fails to include those individuals
that are the most disempowered and that
ultimately stand to gain the most from
that sort of project and
um you know it's it really begs this
question and this is a question that's
been well studied in the participatory
research literature can Community
engagement really Drive transformation
at the community scale especially if it
doesn't include those who really uh
stand to gain the most
so
um to better explore this question I
think it's useful to think about
Pathways that are
um that are trackable options for
Community engagement and this starts the
more practical part of today's
presentation you know so transformation
at system scale
um Can require a lot of different things
not least of which is is coordinated
governance including policy influencing
and a limitation of conventional
community-based participatory research
is that a lot of the objectives are
internal to that community and and
that's important sure absolutely but
also in some ways limits the potential
for that research and those learnings to
influence the broader agenda of Food
Systems transformation that often spills
out and includes other actors external
to a particular community so
um this just goes to show that you know
translating these local insights into
meaningful policy actions especially at
increasing scales is a huge Challenge
and something that participatory
research practitioners have not quite
cracked
um so
uh perhaps it's useful to think about
different ways of of engaging
communities on a spectrum from not
transformative to Super transformative
where we think of you know uh
interventions of our communities are not
consulted in intervention design as
being really not conducive to
transformative action but then we can uh
think of classical community-based
participatory research as you know being
somewhat moderate on the spectrum of its
potential for contributing to Food
Systems transformation you know in
community-based participatory research
we often Empower communities to
independently or with necessary support
address issues of local concern with
methods and tactics that are valuable
and important to them but that does stop
short of communicating those learnings
into broader systems of knowledge and
change that can result in the sort of
foundation of governance required to
affect meaningful and sustainable Food
Systems transformation at scale so this
is where we think about
um
the the level of involvement of
communities that in that positions them
well to influence uh the way a food
system is governed and and possibly the
policy agenda that dictates some of
those governance aspects so
um
and I think now it's a good time to to
talk about a very important uh
constraint of participatory research
which is the level of participation and
the parts of the process where where
community members participate
um of course there is this hugely
important caveat which is that
participation is time and effort and and
community members especially those who
are vulnerable for for many intersecting
reasons often don't have the time or the
desire to be it to be highly engaged or
overly engaged in these processes that
they can sometimes see as external to
them so if we look at the outermost ring
here uh this is a level of involvement
called Empower you know where we're
thinking about communities leading
research decision making and that level
of empowerment is important but it can
be quite idealized and in practice it's
very difficult to achieve a situation
where where at the community level
the most vulnerable are empowered to
take a leading role so the reality is
that across the the process of research
from design to dissemination and to
partnering and and so on and so forth
there are varying levels of Engagement
that have to be necessarily informed by
the needs and desires of the community
um so this is uh a perennial constraint
of uh of traditional community-based
participatory research because
oftentimes while the internal benefits
of that research are clear and
discernible to the community members
they don't often get propelled into a
space where they feel that their
insights translate into broader outcomes
that are experienced by full Food
Systems and that have the potential to
scale I see a question there will be
time for questions at the end I suspect
um
but uh yeah so with that in mind uh
there is uh there is hope after all and
and these uh complex realities have
resulted in
um a range of different techniques for
engaging communities that have evolved
over time you know the action research
uh discipline has you know a
decades-long history and over time we've
really been refining and and resolving
many of these barriers to meaningful
involvement of communities and we've
resulted in in methods like uh
participatory rural appraisal and and
farmer field schools which are part of
the Canon of participatory research and
have you know real evidence supporting
their effectiveness in driving progress
and enhancing livelihood gains and
access to to nutritious foods and and
and Food Systems in a number of contexts
but these often do stop short of
translating into longer term uh Food
Systems governance realities and so this
is sort of a driver of the work that
um I did here at Cornell with with
Rebecca
um and it's sort of imagining uh next
generation of community-based
participatory research that not only
embeds the the process of research
within communities but also uses that
research in such a way that it
automatically sort of has an engagement
with Global Knowledge systems and with
and to to be poised to make a change in
a in a broader Food Systems context so
this is where an example comes in of the
farmer research Network or FRN which was
a core part of my dissertation research
here at Cornell
um you know we we really find that
farmer research networks and these
aligned approaches that try and use a a
core of participatory research to inform
a system level engagement can be very
promising and the the evidence is still
uh rather recent and new on on these
approaches but we do see a lot of
potential from my study and and others
um that that this is a way that we can
influence
system scale relevance so Pharma
research Networks
in general use
networks of engaged Farmers as the name
implies across numerous geographies
sharing
concerns and realities
um that and it really enables the farmer
research Network as a as a Cooperative
to be a nucleus of change and a conduit
supporting the transmission of Knowledge
from the local into the global spaces
and um this is done through building
Partnerships and through generating
evidence and through enhancing the
important agency Dimension that that
participatory research so um so rightly
focuses on
um and uh I think this sort of model of
embedding community-based participatory
research in a process of of transmitting
knowledge into the global Innovation
System has a lot of traction to to uh to
amplify the influence of community
engagement in in Food Systems
transformation
so um just to briefly recap
um an example from my work here at
Cornell we established kassan a farmer
research Network in India that was
really geared toward giving a collective
voice to vulnerable farmers and
particularly
um in enabling them to address important
concerns they had in preserving the
grain that they depended on for their
household nutrition but also for their
Economic Security so um during this
study we engaged Farmers across six
communities in in a single state in
Northern India and they co-identified
grain spoilage as as a foremost concern
that you know had both nutrition
consequences and real livelihood
implications because they can't sell
spoiled grain to the market which was a
key source of income for them so we um
did an in-home trial of hermetic grain
storage which if you've heard me speak
uh on this stage before you've probably
heard me talk about that before
um and we made sure that we weren't just
giving out these sacks but we were
establishing sort of a local uh a local
system that was supportive of this
intervention we partnered with local
shopkeepers in the marketplace to ensure
that there would be a retail supply if
that if the demand took off for this
product and we learned that
um that through training and capacity
building and in-home trials that allowed
Farmers to see the success of this
product with their own eyes there was a
lot of of buy-in and we even conducted
participatory cost benefit analysis that
enabled the farmers to understand that
by investing in this new technology they
could you know profit more by reducing
their food the losses to to insect pests
and so on so what we learned is that the
technology really worked and the farmers
really knew it
um the farmers began seeking out the
product in the market and the FRN served
um as a conduit connecting these
vulnerable Farmers to local governments
and extension agencies in this system
that seemed to have a lot of legs and a
lot of Merit and it also resulted in
Farmers enhancing their locus of control
or the extent to which they felt that
their action would actually make a
difference in the processes of food
system transformation they really knew
that by championing innovation in in
this small way they had a say over the
amount of impact they could achieve so
you can see here it might not look very
clear on the screen but I'm comparing
two images of what the grain stored in
the Hermetic Sac looked like compared to
a conventionally stored sack you can
perhaps make out that you know 90 of
these grains are eaten out by insects
and you can even see the the weevils in
there as well so it was just night and
day difference and the farmers really
took to their new platform to advocate
for Change and to really
um you know be ambassadors for this
technological innovation among their
peers and in their communities
but I also want to tell sort of a
cautionary tale that revisits
um the vulnerability constraints that I
mentioned at the beginning of the talk
too when farmers are vulnerable to
system shocks they are very risk-averse
and mindsets of risk aversion can
prevent uptake of these sorts of
Innovations for example we did an
estimate of the uh
the price elasticity of demand for these
uh hermetic sacs which cost
substantially more than the traditional
methods to see you know as at increasing
price points how much
how elastic was the demand for that
product meaning if it costs marginally
more would there be a proportionally
marginal change in the extent to which
they would be willing to invest and the
the moral of the story is absolutely
there's a lot of elasticity if it gets
more expensive they're not going to
invest in it even though they know that
it's effective and they saw with their
own eyes how effective it was going to
be but importantly
um you know these two clusters represent
groups of villages that are more alike
to one another than they are different
to one another and these two clusters of
villages expressed quite a high
elasticity of demand if the price
increase they would not be interested in
investing in it but the third cluster
had my much less elastic demand meaning
that whatever we were doing really
worked in those communities and this is
a really interesting cautionary tale but
also an inspiring one because it it
shows that you know if the community is
really buy into it they can with enough
support and and with a spirit of
collective action really buy into the
idea and and choose to invest in it so
um
yeah just to finish up by saying that
communities have specific needs that map
to their specific context there's no
Silver Bullet and this is why this is
exactly why community-based approaches
can can reveal a lot of the nuances and
why Innovation does or doesn't take on
so um with the last few minutes of my
talk and I know I'm running short on
time and I want to leave time for
discussion I just want to give a bit of
an overview about what gain is and what
we are trying to do at
um the Global Alliance for improved
nutrition so
um gain is a Swiss based organization
headquartered in Geneva Switzerland that
was founded in 2002 and our vision as an
organization is uh healthier diets for
all especially the most vulnerable and
that emerge from food systems that are
more sustainable in light of of
environmental challenges and the mission
of our organization is to improve the
consumption of healthy diets for all
especially the most vulnerable by
improving the availability affordability
uh desirability and sustainability of
nutritious and safe food
um and my role in the organization is
the technical officer for reaching the
very poor and the program lead for
social protection which I'll talk about
in a moment so you can see that my work
is specifically
targeting the most vulnerable which is
Central to our our organization's
mission
um in terms of what gain does in the
general sense we have a number of
diverse programs that are focused
broadly on making food systems work for
everyone and they're organized around
three goals impact sustainability and
scale which I suspect are quite
straightforward
um and we have cross-cutting beams that
really underpin all of our work
including gender environment and the
inclusion of the very poor
um and we have four programmatic
clusters that serve as an umbrella that
our work generally operates within and
it will give you a good idea of just
what we're about we do a lot of
large-scale food fortification so
fortification of of food with with
micronutrients we uh support small and
medium Enterprises in in nutrition
through our nutrition Enterprise unit to
ensure that nutrition is a business and
that value chains are supported to
potentiate uh access to nutritious and
safe Foods we do a lot of work in
driving Food Systems change which is
where I fall into the organization and
we also have a huge presence of policy
and governance related work as well and
we work across a number of countries
having country offices in in uh
particularly sub-Saharan Africa South
and Southeast Asia
um and
um now I'll just spend a couple minutes
talking about specifically uh my program
which is social protection so at gained
we really think about social protection
as transformative programs and policies
that uh aim to alleviate the adverse
effects of poverty and to reduce social
inequities and many examples of social
protection you're probably already
familiar with like Direct Cash transfer
programs or in-kind nutrition support
like School meals or or food food
vouchers
um there are also social protection
benefits in terms of on or
underemployments and Social Security uh
and then there isn't a growing uh body
of examples of social protection that
are driven toward Financial inclusion
and human capital development and so
um as part of the organization and I as
the program lead in this area am tasked
with understanding how this General
theme fits into our broader us of making
nutritious diets accessible to those who
are experiencing poverty
um what we do in our social Protection
Program is work through evidence-based
engagement with a number of Partners
gain being an alliance and an alliance
Builder is really driven by the idea of
partnership uh uh to achieve our our
shared aims so we work a lot with
governments and private sector
stakeholders and other partners
um uh particularly to amplify Community
perspectives to leverage social
protection as uh uh a transformative and
livelihood
supporting activity also to mainstream
the use of social protection mechanisms
as catalysts of positive nutrition
Behavior change and we're also taking
advantage of our history as an
organization touching on value chains to
make sure that social Protection Systems
talk to and and integrate with value
chains for nutritious foods to ensure
that governments are able to supply and
and enhance access to nutritious Foods
through value chains based approaches
and then importantly we're trying to
facilitate crosstalk between
um between country contexts to in uh
sort of South South learning volitions
to ensure that the successes and
learnings from the social protection
experience for nutrition impact in
countries are shared and that we can
synergize and and learn from one another
so um just to wrap up I'll say that it's
not an altogether dissimilar Pathway to
Food Systems transformation than what uh
I've then what I've been working on at
at Cornell and in the space of
community-based participatory research
the
the functions of social protection for
vulnerable communities are rather
resemble resembling the functions of
collective action if it's done properly
and in a way that is really true to the
spirit of of community empowerment
um so
um I think I will leave it there and I
hope we have some time for questions but
I do want to acknowledge uh a number of
folks especially Rebecca for the
continued support and the broader sips
faculty and and students as well as the
Tata Cornell Institute and DNS and the
program of international nutrition at
Cornell and of course very grateful to
gain and particularly our program
Services team of which I'm a part uh for
uh enabling me to do all this work and
most importantly perhaps to all the
farmers and communities who drive this
work and will continue to inform our
agenda in Food Systems transformation so
thank you
I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about how you got
involved working with game and what your
path coming out of Cornell and two games
like you always have a thought that you
would go into the NGO space coming into
grad school just maybe elaborate a
little bit more on that for those of us
who are just sure repeat the question
yeah
um very good question so the question
was um about you know how I got into
gain and whether I always knew that I
wanted to go the NGO route when I was
navigating grad school and the the great
beyond
um the answer to that question is no
actually I had no intention of going
into the NGO space I fully thought I
would uh be another Rebecca Nelson uh
frankly
um so it was sort of a surprise to me
um but I've always been driven more by
the work than the organization or the
sector you know um throughout my time at
Cornell I really learned about and
invested in the idea of community
empowerment and in the context of
international agricultural development
and for me it wasn't important to
whether I would do that work in a
university context or in an NGO space
but rather you know what is the amount
of impact I can have for those
vulnerable beneficiaries and I
ultimately we found that the word gain
was doing was a great path toward that
on the ground impact
yeah great question
Anthony I wonder if you
had those three communities
who had elastic and inelastic
um
sure responses and say a little bit more
about about them and what caused the
elasticity or the
uh in elasticity yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the question was
um with respect to these three uh
communities or or you know Village
clusters
um you know what resulted in this
different difference in in the
elasticity of demand that we observed
um there were a number of factors
um I think the most contributive factors
included the fact that in this cluster
the local leaders of the FRN were very
vocal and they bought into the idea and
it you know
um the way that these communities worked
uh meant that the local leaders were
entrusted with sort of driving the
agenda and many of the farmers really
mobilized together on the uh you know in
alignment with the farmers that they
knew and trusted and I think the fact
that in this Village cluster we had
really vocal leaders who bought into the
idea you know they drove the whole
operation and it was really beautiful to
see whereas our the leadership was less
strong in the other two clusters but it
is also
I think very much related to the
production system the cropping systems
which I think you all as an audience
would appreciate the cluster that
exhibited the least elasticity of demand
was the cluster that primarily produced
rice and wheat in rotation
um and we
we primarily advocated for the use of
these hermetic sacs in rice and wheat
particularly wheat and so the fact that
those crops were so major as drivers of
those local economies I think played a
huge role whereas in these two clusters
which had a different cropping system
that included more diverse crops like
Maize and like ground nuts which were
not as conducive to being stored with
this technology
that probably resulted in it overall it
boils down to local leaders and the fact
and the proportional share of wheat to
the local economy
yeah great question hope that answers it
yeah
um so I guess my question was just
around like the role of like an
organization like gain or someone who's
like coming as an outside of perspective
and like how can they best like sort of
support like communities and being
Community Driven when they are sort of
like I don't know in some ways like set
against that as like someone who's
coming into privilege or someone who's
like not a part of that community
yeah very good question I'll repeat the
question
um or paraphrase hopefully I get it
right so um the question was uh
regarding you know how we as an
organization as as gain approach this
idea of you know us coming into these
Community contexts as Outsiders or with
privilege and you know sort of having
that
um external presence in a in a community
space
um this is a very real Challenge and I
think one that's shared across all
organizations in the development sector
you know how are how do we
empower
the local agenda to be The Driver of the
global agenda and that's a really tough
question the the way that I've really
approached it in my work is by
advocating for the you know empowerment
of our local country-based teams and and
you know making sure that at the country
level we build up the capacity in
partnership with governments and other
stakeholders so it's not just gain
coming in and doing some such thing it's
actually gain coming in and supporting
this more transformative action that
will hopefully have resounding and
scalable effects context of the broader
local policy agenda but it is a major
Challenge and at some level development
orgs are always seen as Outsiders when
they step into a community but that's
not always a bad thing in fact it holds
a lot of promise sometimes
community members as part of
transformative change
that emphasis that I heard here and yet
when I hear Global Alliance for improved
nutrition and I'm wondering who are
who's in The Alliance I mean are you not
also acting at the sort of
Hollis highest level of policy also
where we were chatting last night you
know I was hearing you know very high
level
um policy makers involved in your
current you know daily work you know you
see you're moving and shaking at the
highest levels of you know head to State
types or their immediate deputies
and and how do you bridge that because
when I think of structural change or
transformation in general I'm like a to
B is like a structure aged structure
means who's changing what what are we
even talking about sometimes it seems
very abstract and how do you get the
highest level you know the policy level
in the low and the community members on
the same page are achieving this yeah I
don't even understand what the
transformation does and how it's being
achieved but can you come in sort of the
daily work at game that you're doing now
and sure
yeah that's a really good question
um the there's no like easy answer to it
but the the
overall sense that I've gotten and the
one that I try to use in my work is that
when we work with you know policy makers
and people that wield power we should be
focused on making them aware of
community needs and giving them
actionable models by which to make their
power work for people at Community level
and it's a very it's a tough challenge
because people that are mired in
institutional bureaucracies are often
rather resistant to thinking at the
granular human level but um you know for
example in my work in the social
Protection Program we are really
committed to this idea of human-centered
design you know making sure that we
understand how social protection
mechanisms impact people and we sort of
help the people who make decisions about
the design and delivery of these
programs
respond to those particular needs it's
not we we want to get away from the idea
of these you know government agencies or
what have you making decisions that they
think will work for the communities we
want to instead Empower those government
agencies to meaningfully listen and
address the needs of those communities
through
through raising you know human-centered
design questions as an option for them
and through developing forums whereby
policy makers can sit face to face with
beneficiaries and understand their
concerns in a way that leads to policy
action so that's sort of the the way I
describe it
yeah
good question following on that um does
gain intersect or interact directly with
program managers at major federal
funding agencies
and uh and if not do you think that
would be
uh practical and effective
uh yeah so the question uh was regarding
whether gain interacts with like Federal
funding agencies and and if not or you
know would that be effective or
meaningful
um the the answer is yeah uh we do a lot
of interaction and like any organization
you know we are always driven by sort of
the evolving priorities of countries and
donors and the broader you know context
of of need in the nutrition space and so
you know we operate uh with a lot of
donors priorities in minds and often
those donor priorities are reflective of
country governments priorities and you
know we take a lot of this multilateral
feedback into account
um but I think it is a particular
strength of gain that we are so driven
toward Partnerships and we have really
nice uh and trusting relations with with
a lot of actors in governments
um and particularly in our in the
countries where we work that can help
support those sorts of things
yeah
sure so what are the local offices what
do those actually look like
whose staff there do you actually hire a
local community members to staff those
offices and then how did those offices
communicate with your office in uh
Switzerland I believe so what what's
that actually look like uh like boots on
the ground sort of yeah well I must say
that our country offices are way more
lively and exciting than our you know
our what we call our representative
offices I think yeah so we have country
offices in 10 or so countries and they
are they have really robust staff that
do very important programming work and
project management and they are the
boots on the ground and more often than
not they are local staff which is I
think really powerful you know that
we're not transplanting folks into these
places we're investing in in that local
capacity and so yeah our uh our country
offices look very much like any business
in the in those cities in those
countries and it's it's actually rather
inspiring
would you like a little bit more who's
in The Alliance and a little bit about
the history of the alliances or what's
on your sort of you know your fun burger
at the moment sure
um so
I'm I don't I don't have a clear answer
for like who is the alliance but I think
uh that is rooted in our history sort of
in from the moment we emerged you know I
probably was more of a a defined
Alliance in those days but now the the
alliance as far as I interpret it is
more about
you know a commitment to Alliance
building and to investing in these
Partnerships you know engagement and
partnership really drives our work so
even though possibly in the early days
of gain it was a definable Alliance now
it is really sort of a testament to our
way of working that really is driven by
Partnerships in the alliance building
yeah
sure wouldn't you how would you describe
your certain current battles or battle
or main thing that you're up to oh well
uh right now I'm in the throes of
setting up a really big program in uh
for Asian countries and to African
countries and it's uh gotten me quite
excited I'm pursuing a lot of the
material that I described in the
um in the slide about what our social
Protection Program does we're setting up
interventions on you know using social
protection as a mechanism for nutrition
Behavior change and we're using
um you know we're partnering with
self-help groups in India for example to
understand how connection to social
Protection Systems can be an opportunity
for livelihood gains and income
generation and so we're doing a number
of these things and so my day-to-day
life is very full of setting up all of
that
now
yeah
um do you see your just understanding of
participatory research but not Pharma
but it's a misery but this General
Community participatory research
um sort of being relevant in the work
that you do now so you said that you're
planning on Intervention strategies do
you see
participatory research as a needs to get
you that information and sort of guide
you through what intervention would work
yeah very good question so the question
was about whether and to what extent
possibly I see participatory research
elements finding their way into my
current work and whether that seems
useful I would say yes very much so
um we in our interventions won't be
necessarily doing community
community-based participatory research
in that classical sense but in as far as
we are invested in amplifying
beneficiary voice and and committed to
human-centered design we are using a lot
of those same themes to try and
understand how we give a platform to
those vulnerable people and how we
articulate their narratives in ways that
are meaningful both to them and for the
broader policy making environment and
for the social protection system so I
would say yeah
um the skills I gained at Cornell are
very much applicable to what I'm doing
now and that is a PSA
um
well out of time and if anybody have a
last question or should we give Anthony
another thanks
thanks for having me
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu